[Music]
i will say and this is such an old man
thing to say but i'll say it anyway
there is no magic bullet
for growth
and the tools change so
i would suggest
getting a book like the 22 immutable
laws of marketing
reading a short chapter called the law
of category i believe i put an updated
slash edited version of that in either
tools of titans or tribe mentors because
i think it's that valuable
read the law of category
read 1000 true fans by kevin kelly which
you can find on kk.org
these will give you
principles adaptable principles that
will allow you to build a unique
position
in the minds of people who will become
diehard evangelists
if you do that
which takes consistency over time and it
takes focus more than anything else
a lot of the other dominoes will tip
over
without any additional effort
but
if instead of learning how to draw
as an analogy you're focused on whether
you should use a ballpoint pen or a
fountain pen or pastels or crayons or
watercolors
meaning
the the different technologies and tools
clubhouse versus tick tock versus
instagram versus oh vine remember that
oops
uh oh
if your promotional engine was based on
that uh oh
facebook business pages oh
yeah
you're gonna need to boost to reach your
audience now sorry about that
uh
there's too much fragility in a tactics
or tools based approach so i think the
principles are most important
but
i recognize also that perhaps i am just
too far
from the nascent
years in which i built my blog following
to provide a good answer i will say
though that i built a very very very
very popular blog when
practically no one knew who the hell i
was and i did that by writing posts that
i hoped
ten percent of my then very small
audience would love
i did not write posts that i wanted 100
of my audience to like
and i do the same thing with podcasting
i think it works really well so i do not
expect my entire audience to love any
episode and if i tried to do that i
think i would shoot myself on the foot i
expect that my active audience will be
in a rotation in every
fourth or fifth or maybe 10th episode
they will love so much that they will
send it to 10 of their friends that is
how i think about it and i i believe at
least so far it has been extremely
extremely effective
one of the pieces of feedback someone
gave me on my show was that
not every episode is relevant to them
right i did an episode where i
interviewed a professional car buyer
and they were like i don't have a car so
this episode's pointless they're like
maybe you should
change the show so that everything's
always relevant to everyone and my
answer was i don't know i i'm gonna buy
a car i wanted to talk to someone that
professionally does this and that's
super interesting to me so
you know just skip it and go to the next
one
do you feel similarly you said you know
one in five to ten people love that
episode do you care or or do you think
they're listening to the other
five to nine episodes
i don't care
i i literally spend zero time thinking
about it because
and this this might sound strange but
for me to be
for me to have fun
for this to be a
joyful experience that i look forward to
the podcast needs to have a certain
essence
a certain poll for me
and it has to have a certain dosage
so i have a very infrequent podcast i do
it
on average four
times per month or i publish four long
form episodes per month we didn't really
talk about recording cadence which we
could talk about
but on average i published four
long-form interviews per month at one
point it was six episodes
and then i noticed a few months into
doing that
i was starting to drag my feet
a little bit
and
it began to feel like a job like an
obligation and i noted that quickly
thankfully and i said this is no good
if i keep this up i'm gonna stop doing
the
podcast or i'm just going to be unhappy
doing it in which case what the [ __ ] am
i doing because i don't need to do it
and i then ratcheted back the frequency
of the podcast to the point where it
felt good
so it's there's a dosage question
i.e frequency there's also an essence
poll question so for me i have to follow
my own interest and to be of
a good steward of my own self-care but
to also be of greatest service to the
people who are listening i need to keep
doing this or
at least i hope to keep doing it maybe i
don't need to but i would like to keep
doing this and to be able to
grow over time and share those lessons
the only way i'm going to do that is if
i
am drawn
to continue doing this because i enjoy
it so
if i decide to do an episode with a
violin appraiser and it gets 10
listeners i don't [ __ ] care at all as
long as i enjoy the episode i do not
care and i will say that over time
that not caring is the ultimate form of
caring because you can
cultivate an audience who is interested
in stepping into weird strange corners
of the world
into interests and professions and lives
that they perhaps otherwise would have
ignored or avoided
so your audience will also change in how
they relate to you
over time
and at least in my experience
they i hope
have realized that sometimes it is the
episode they least would have expected
to want to listen to that they end up
liking the most
of perhaps
the last 20 episodes i've done so i
think my listeners are more and more
willing to give me the benefit of the
doubt and try something strange
you